over the years I've had some issues
regarding anxiety and depression and one
of the things that I thought might help
me would be to get a pug I adopted a pug
puppy his name is Phil and I've had Phil
since he was a seat weeks old and could
fit in the palm of my hand before I got
Phil when I was feeling bad I would look
at pictures of pugs because they're so
cute that they look like they shouldn't
exist they look like a gift from an
ancient civilization that we've
unearthed I can't believe that they made
this Phil can accurately be described as
the runt of the litter but what he lacks
in size he has magnified many times over
in cuteness his favorite things are
hanging out on the couch with me going
on a walk with me kissing my face and
chasing a laser beam we do that laser
green thing like you do I'm a novelist
I've been having a little trouble
selling a book finally though I got a
break and this publisher asked me to
write a book for them and I was over the
moon because this was guaranteed income
so I just toiled on this thing for
months and months kind of going through
savings and then after about nine months
of really hard work I got a call from my
agent she called and told me that the
book contract was being cancelled for
reasons out of our control I felt like I
just need one break and I thought that
book was the break and then it broke so
I hung up with my agent I definitely
very quickly wound up on the floor and I
lay there for a while just kind of
spiraling down and Phil wanders into the
room now the thing about Phil is that if
I'm laying down if I'm bending over if
my face is in any gravitational way
accessible to him he will kiss it over
and over and over but instead of doing
that he saw me waiting there and he did
this thing that he had never done where
he just kind of tilted his head back and
forth like he didn't understand what he
was seeing then he kind of trotted over
to the other side of the room got his
favorite toy and I thought he was gonna
bring it over to me to play and I was
like I'm not gonna be able to play but
he didn't do that
he just kind of buried his face in my
side near my heart which felt like it
was breaking in that moment he did
literally the one thing on earth that
could um
which was just to love me he loves me
and doesn't want me to be hurting and
that's exactly how I feel about him
[Music]